[Musik]
am vorabend zum ersten weltkrieg erzählt
produzent die auf der spur vorigen wahl
schweiz für eine revolution kampf hätte
sie nahmen mit rumer bekannt ist ein
begriff
fritz button radikaler sozialist
[Musik]
ordensträger fotos der frauen statt
einer turbulenten
der geschichte der menschheit knut zum
leben
[Musik]
der traum vom platten sozialistische
weltrevolution arbeit ausmacht
[Musik]
der lärm ist das vorbild schicksals
freundschaft vonn platten zum verhängnis
wird
was ist das für ein xii der fritz
platten und was ist geblieben vom 7
und warum wird ausgerechnet der
klassenkampf am schluss erschoss ihren
eigenen genossen
[Musik]
chinas
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es ist da geht langsam wie mit nach zug
unterwegs 700 kilometer nördlich von
moskau
467 verstorben ist das ritz platten in
der einsamen misst ins dorf andermatt
zwar nummer paar brocken russisch die
aber zuversichtlich hier mehr
überfordert
bibliothekarin galina vom empfang bin
ich aber sehr schwach wir freuen uns sie
hier bei uns in jan doch mal zu begrüßen
brot und salz für sie was sie muss
machen
brot ist als dunkle dass sie von jeher
bruch weil hier die gastronomie
[Musik]
definitiv auch wieder andere wahl
london das ist stoff russische provinz
[Musik]
und hier geht es dort sachlich fritz
glatten straße ins labor wird dann bitte
an die 70
[Musik]
galina führt mit bibliothek und hier
geht es schon bietet eine überraschung
guten tag wir haben euch heute zu uns in
die bibliothek eingeladen um euch von
einem erstaunlichen menschen zu erzählen
von fritz platten
sein schicksal ist traurig mit unserem
bezirk nie an oma verbunden
fritz platten war ein vertreter der
internationalen kommunistischen
arbeiterbildung ein freunde und
mitkämpfer von wladimir iljitsch lenin
und hobbyhistoriker schweizer
revolutionär
[Musik]
wir müssen wissen er war ein
ausserordentlicher mensch er hat viel
geleistet für die sowjetunion unseren
staat das was wir heute russland nennen
eure kollegen von der achten klasse
versuchen euch jetzt von ihm zu erzählen
fries karten wurde geboren am 8 juli
1883 im kanton st gallen
wladimir hat mit seiner schüler extra
präsentation ich studiert hochoffiziell
die uniformen dass russland nach seiner
rückkehr in die schweiz wurde er von
einem schweizer militärgericht verhaftet
wegen aufforderung zum streit und zum
schluss gibt's noch st
für ihre katrin wir möchten ihnen diese
dvd überreichen
mit unserer präsentation und
archivmaterial von fritz platten
vielen dank wunderbar
[Applaus]
nach dem vortrag geht es nie anders als
der vladimir wird mit mir der tat oder
fritz platten sie im letzten jahr hat
verbraucht
nico eines ehemals straflager vom stalin
wie das rad von der philosophie gewarnt
assistiert erwartet zudem später
[Musik]
hier briefe die einzige verwandte von
fritz boxen
im altersheim mit der stadt wurden seine
schwiegertochter hey die platten der
legende fritz linie grenzt aber ihre
schlappe hätte bestimmt dem handy ist
ihre ein guter thomas der uhr ankunft am
fritz wo so oder im russland komme dies
sind die russische vorfahren rasch das
sind die russischen vor fliegt stocker
das ist das schon wörter vor dem
großvater fragen von jokers vater oder
auch eine chance setzt holger die schöne
russische studentin eine von vielen
frauen von fritz platten arbeitet zürich
1912 karate yamaha saison kam der fritz
junior der mann vom handy der name
platten hätten handy und ihr mal schlapp
macht
[Musik]
es ist möglich dass ich dann ist das das
abkommen ich sie kommunistisch sie ja
das ist der fritz button junior der mann
vom handy war 2000 verstorben ist und
das imperium der vater habe land lebt
erzählt sie im film vom russischen
fernsehen fans in der nutzung ab zieht
es ist auch von münster kurz nach der
wende afghanen der fritz platten junior
es muss erst mal toppen sein vater durch
[Musik]
das ist ein sehr wichtiger moment für
mich dass ich die dokumente über meinen
vater studieren kann den jahrelang
wusste ich nicht zufrieden
[Musik]
jahrelang hat der fritz junior und nicht
vor sein vater wusste david russland
klappt und in ausburg zurückschickt
doch zwei verschiedene besaß seine
helfer sammler verzaubert ohne krämpfe
im archiv vor unibibliothek basel finden
über 100 ordner gefüllt mit dokuments
über sie wollten
[Musik]
russland ist ein riesiger 1 archiv auge
gewaltig und zieht sich wie ein roter
faden durchs lager von britz platten 8
383 unteroffiziere arbeiterfamilie
später bricht er ab und geht afrika er
macht mit 105 mit revolutionärer unruhe
im saal richtung sozialismus hätten
punkt aus zürich erdplatten revolutionär
russische krise mit der historiker täter
wurden gefasst
warum habt ihr um 1900 sowie große
frauen russische studentin kathrin fries
hatte jahre vom ersten weltkrieg und
zwar sieht 18 48 sogar schon die
geburtsurkunde steht in sehr liberalen
asylpraxis kann das heißt studenten und
studentinnen diktatur sei ein
demokratischer regime russland
deutschland von bismarck die hand die
schweiz ferner hat sich für eine schrieb
universitäten studieren was er behauptet
habe ist einfach viel überhaupt nicht
erlaubt miteinander ist das nicht
möglich sie schweizer städten ins taxi
vor der demokratie von demokratische
kampf wurde noch am ehesten bei fritz
platten x faszination für die russen
er ist von anfang an feuer und flamme
für die russische zustand und dann für
die russische revolution und hat den auf
das ist kein zufall
russische frauen piraten und instagram
rechte platter herstellen als
ein-mann-show russland das russische
zustand und die russische studentin
eigentlich dynamisiert worden ist
fritz platten am züri 1912 mit der
bikini russische studentin olga sehr gut
vor akkurater und engagiere sich ihre
arbeiten bewegung
[Musik]
der flieht sie jetzt knapp ghriskey
stieg die sozialdemokratische partei die
sozialisten krise gilt als
hervorragender organisator
[Musik]
auf der brust der frau anni kramer
dani ist überzeugte sozialistin wieder
fit politisiert der schwere jugend jeder
proletarier familie kämpft an vorderster
front für bessere bedingungen für die
arbeiter filmdokumente aus grafing ist
damit die er vor kämpfen vertrag von der
frauen
inzwischen ist sie gestorben naja und
die bibliothekarin die krise jahr vor
[Musik]
nach und nach habe ich mich aufregen
vor dem ersten weltkrieg als wahrer
industriellen und wirtschaftlichen
aufschwung aber auf kosten der arbeiter
[Musik]
das ist musik richtig verdient das ist
auch das ist dass ich es machen das ist
die politische große revolution sie wird
[Musik]
im vergleich zum ausland ist schweiz
hoch technisiert vom fortschritt
profitierte bürgertum
[Musik]
situation vor der arbeiterschaft ist
wirklich desolat wie sie an zu wenig
verdient sie haben sich leistete vor sie
hat sogar 10 sek und das ist dass ich
halt irgendwann aus brauchen wir sind
nämlich an er dann da muss man
irgendetwas machen also es ist wirklich
an elan die situation
und das hat dann halt zur rebellion für
die schweiz dafür demonstriert wie vor
nach dass ich das läuft vor schmiedet er
ich hab das konzert stellen also
kreative pr monat aber sich und sehr
diszipliniert und mit reisig und mit
erhöhter sich also danke und frauen
gemacht
sie sind überzeugt davon dass bisher
bester das ist ein segen hat mercedes
mit asbest und dass man es kaum
verbessere man streikt und hat er viele
vorschlag bei milonga am schluss und das
ist schon gewaltige kraft eigentlich
oder die hinter sich fritz platten kürze
der zeit zu der radikale streikführer
mit genosse und revolutionäre emigranten
trifft sich im gewerkschaftshaus
eintracht statt
der tag gar nicht mit dem historiker
peter huber heute ist die auch die
eintracht zürcher theater am neumarkt
wie wichtig ist dir das ehemalige
arbeiter versammlungslokal eintracht im
amt behalten
das ist sicher die neuralgische punkt
für sich arbeiten bewegen sie aus dem
fenster klopfen
das einsitzige passiert das sind
vorbereitungen passiert für aktionen und
so haben und mit stolz sein durch die
eigenen verein und ich sicher sie das
anteilig von der sozialistischen
bewegung stärker denn je wird macht die
gesellschaft übernehme und zum
sozialismus führen
was ist dir da ebene droht platten der
fritz platten hat versucht um riesa
lobte der ganze laden zusammenzuhalten
das heißt er hat versucht an die
strömungen vor den arbeiter und drei
kurz bringen
er hat wohl dass man all die
verschiedenen strömungen als katapult
das bürgertum aufbaut bürgertum
mitarbeiter zu der größte teil nur
schöne sache verachtet kann hat aber es
hat führt arbeiter bei artikeln
fritz behaupten wird das verhältnis
anderer wieder arbeitet ist wie thomann
bekannt und beliebt genossen schritt
sein bild von dreisten absatz und man
sah es in den guten stuben der arbeiter
hängen und in den kammern der fabrik
mädchen geschmückt mit einer roten nelke
oder einem pendel nennt sich stolz
berufsrevolutionär und schaffet aus
generalsekretär vor alaska im volkslied
[Musik]
da bricht 1940 starb sie involviert
titels millionen mal im ring
landwirt verbaut zu doc größe insgesamt
zehn millionen jobs macht mobil
[Musik]
dort oben dran
es bliebt verschoben im sledge nichts
schrecklicheres
und auch unseres jahr nach ausbruch vom
krieg 1950 zur hoch käme internationalen
sozialisten konferenz organisiert vom sp
nationalrat robert green day mit 15
[Musik]
für glaubten bcv zum schicksal hier
lehrte der link rennen davor die
freundschaft sequenz präsident bruno
mars ist wurde die konferenz berry und
worden ist wenn man das zimmer waltz
nicht unbedingt geschätzten 80 personen
position gebracht sie geschlafen
also von deiner kontrolle der läden
kommt größer master zum alltag von der
frauen hockey fight am haus wohnt eine
frau die von einer kommune
das heißt dass hinter der fassade hält
sozialistisch stritten über die haut von
kritik von arbeiterbewegung kommunisten
und sozialisten hat sich hier abzeichnet
das sieht man die sache wo völlig system
zieht sich das aus ich habe das blut der
topversion große schuhe wo die konferenz
den start gegangen ich konferenz ist
quasi talmacsi aus versammlung für
ornithologen zu fördern us im nachhinein
hat sich danach klar gesehen dass das
sexy wo die vier tag hat auch rosi
der extremist training erwartet die
proletarische revolution hund aber da
nichts tun gibt aber bisher hätte linie
wo fortschritt hinter in berlin in
leipzig baar in der schweiz im exil
1916 vor baden hier express bibliothek
als esszimmer laut stadt aber spaß rund
um die platte nicht natürlich an einer
für mich und das ist
für lenin und der platten weltweit
revolution benötigt mit clown
die zürcher bibliotheken schritt der
lenin tagen 18
hier entwickelte politische theorie wo
später weltberühmt worden sind
[Musik]
vor dem russisch der fritz platten dort
begeistert
ich habe aus dem munde von lenin noch
kein grobes rohes wort vernommen aber
setzte die mir das blut augenblicklich
erstarren ließen portfolios käme
verbindung mit der revolution als
russlands und des ovid februar 1910
revolution russland auf das training
überzeugt worten zufolge stützt der zog
[Musik]
aus bald geschichte geschrieben
das wäre der februar revolution hat der
lenin und die anderen russischer
flüchtlinge nicht anders will als
möglichst schnell weg
bacchus dem klimasystem der innenspiegel
gas sofort nach russland ziehen und die
idee für die rede jetzt kam für das
erstmals die möglichkeit sehe ich habe
wir waren intensive zeit ist wann in 72
hat der linie und sind kampfgenossen in
russland nur gefangen ist riskiert
kamera betrifft lehnen die chance für
ihn gibt es nur vage zu dass europa wie
zentrieren
[Musik]
mit dem zug durch ezri und gewitter bis
nach sankt petersburg
[Musik]
für kaplan braucht unterstützung vom
budget her ist ethik die tüte stecken
200 stationen fronten im westen mit
frankreich und england und ich musste
mit russland sie wird ostfront entlasten
die akten zeigen die deutsche
unterstütze die russische revolutionär
mit millionen sie deshalb macht bringen
und friede mit russland dank keine
kontakte bester lenin dass die deutschen
weiter unterstützen und das ist die
große stunde von fritz platten plänen
vertrauten heikle mission an dann
übergibt die platten im deutschen
botschafter am lehniner bedingungen für
die zugfahrt
die tücher sie verschlangen der platte
organisiert die zugreise begleitet die
rund 30 exil russen
es geht los zur em nun in 210 tagen
statisch discount situations russlands
nach anzahl sturz instabil
sie wisse nicht was erwartet
mit dem lernen hockey und schloss nicht
revolutionär mit ihm zog hunderte trotz
kritik
und sie bewiesen humor entweder wir sind
die sechs monaten minister oder wir
hängen
so hetzt discounter ist so genannte
kombi wird kein kontakt mit typischer
ärzte möglich vorwurf sie ganz von vorn
herein
china erleben der schritt begleiten wer
in westeuropa hätten 1917 zu prophezeien
gewagt dass diese armen schlucker führer
und lenker eines 130 millionen volks
werden könnten
und tatsächlich am lehnen sie plan geht
auf
sie werden oktober revolution setzt sagt
er
[Musik]
nummer paar monate nach der ankunft von
zog sie die lenin und seine bolschewiki
am 8
[Musik]
jahrhundert später bin ich in dem
historiker alexander barth limo auf dem
roten platz in moskau
diese konnte man einen sitzplatz zu zeit
der revolution da in russland ja frist
laden das war die verkörperung der
evolution von diesem internationalen ev
dass die russische revolution in die
büsche wirken in der welt hervorgerufen
haben und außerdem wer war der freund
von linien absolut eine große gestalt in
der sowjetunion
deswegen waren überall bekannt wo war
die dass russland hütte der platten der
zug mit dem lernen dennett organisiert
und die revolution nicht stattgefunden
hat
was sie eine werkstatt ro
[Musik]
für alle sondern nimmt mediziner maligen
zentraler partner yahoo sowie frank m
[Musik]
hört sie hier dokumente öffentlich
mit denen internationale komisch der
hetzer alexander barth liegend
beschäftige zum fritz platten
wer war denn diese stets klatten jahr
ein romantiker wie kann man das
ausführliche erklären da war witte das
kind seiner zeit und offensichtlich
während er in einer der kriegsführenden
echte gewesen wäre wäre bestimmt tapfer
im krieg opel dass überall gruppe das
überlebt hat oder nicht aber in der
schweiz war irgendwie eingeklemmt und
ersuchte immer mit diesen streiks die er
mit organisiert hat und so weiter und so
fort
diese politische betätigung aktiv zu
werden immer wieder platten aus moskau
der traum von der weltrevolution ist
immer hier zum griff nach vorn und der
schweiz arbeiten sie jetzt mit der
politischen vater
vor kommunistischen partei kommentieren
kommunismus verschiedene geländes jahr
ist der lenin führt der kongress ist
stein stand für fritz platten
einschätzung ganz oben im präsidium vom
kongress direkter dem lenin im zentrum
vormacht
[Musik]
zurück in der schweiz gegen die vom
krieg ist der fritz blanc de noir
christen zwischen hier russlands die
schätzer für die ski ständig trifft es
auch mit genosse zu krise siebziger nord
hat sich verschärft es geht quer
unterstützung für die wehrmänner aber
massive zürich arbeiterfamilie
heißhunger ohne staatliche lebensmittel
versorgt geht nicht mehr
es geht noch spießiger ton rauer
klima verhärtet sich im 18
also war ich wirklich sehr revolutionäre
stimmig sie in russland hat es
revolution in deutschland hat revolution
und da hat man gemeint in der schweiz
stellen die das kurz bevor der fritz
blatter ist überzeugt dass er soll
schweiz dummen umsturz der
sp-nationalrat robert grimm und ist
komitee planer der landesstraße fritz
es ist die grösste streik was ihr gar
nicht im land
vorträge unter anderem trost im recht 40
vor arbeitszeit proporzwahl und
altersvorsorge das ist dass ich dass ich
endlich was
der general wille befüllt massiven
militäreinsatz dreharbeiten erschossen
ja das sind tragen mit der sie aber luft
arbeiter los sind
der bundesrat fordert von grimm und im
komitee ultimativ der strecke brauchen
aus angst vor einem bürgerkrieg gibt es
nachher als handelte kompromiss mit der
regierung auch drehtag wieder landesweit
generalstreik abbruch zu schreiben maxi
kompromiss politische kompromiss langsam
ist vorletzter auf parlamentarischem weg
auf demokratischem weg das ist ein
fortschritt
das ist aber nicht der weg von fritz und
der radikale sozialisten
für ihn ist der abbruch von
wanderstrecke furchtbarer schlag der
sozialdemokraten
1921 gründete mit anderen diakonische
partei von der schweiz
[Musik]
als erster nationalrat vor der
kommunisten und anhänger von lenin
verbreitet haltung hunderttausend tote
wären kein preis wenn wir in der schweiz
den sozialismus bringen würden radikale
teil wurde fritz plus trug sich mehr
denn je die bezüge sieht das in der
schweiz schwierig ist wieder so dass
vicky in russland war schinkel der werk
werte zeigen das was er denn jeder
russische werk muss ich los ging stärke
der kommunist platten auf russland
und game muss ins gefängnis nachdem
landesstraße über private probleme im
dritten frau olga hinter klappen
erhöht aus kommunistisch war stand für
die bürgerliche ist dass rhodes
durchgeführte genossen schlecht
angeschrieben
[Musik]
1920 fritz platten die eine schweiz
erwandert und russland zusammen mit
seiner eltern zu dem abi über rettet
jahrhundert kommunisten mit dem gelobten
land
[Musik]
person wird ja später auf der spur von
der frau z damit anderen schwiegervater
vom lehn in der landwirtschaft kommen
ergründet der fritz platten schritt den
klassen bewussten arbeiter ist
sowjetrussland ein land der sehnsucht
erwünscht dort am aufbau einer neuen
gesellschaftsordnung mitarbeiten zu
können
ihn reizt die aufgabe den russischen
bauern helfer und beispiel zu werden
fazit hier liebe stark
zwei verehrerin der von fritz platten
zeigen
[Musik]
nach der revolution haxhi radverkehrs in
kleinen maschinen avia purer schweizer
sieger der xxi
[Musik]
und diese auch eine hose die attraktion
mit traf guten tag jetzt geht das ist
kathrin ich habe ihnen von ihr erzählt
1923 bis 27 lebten hier schweizer
kommunisten hier der vater von fritz
platten
fritz war oft da dieses haus ist 90
jahre alt stellt euch vor und so gut
erhalten
[Musik]
dazu derzeit 380 dfg nie zeigt mit zu
da kommen sie bitte rein schauen sie
diesen rufen den haben auch die
schweizer gebaut
er ist auch schon 90 jahre alt wir haben
sehr kalte winter 30 grad unter null
die rufen heißt das ganze haus nummer ab
und fuhr damit moskau bester stiefvater
[Musik]
deshalb verließen sie bei uns die damals
wie heute sowohl verhalten der schweiz
deshalb kamen sie in unser hungriges
zerstört des denkens bis heute das waren
außergewöhnliche menschen die ihr
eigenes wohlergehen jedem der
gemeinschaft unterordnete
das experiment wagte
zwangskollektivierung von landwirtschaft
feder und tusche probiert ihre anderen
kommunen später unter dem regime von
stalin war für ihn eine kasseler kanzlei
1927 wird der landwirtschafts kommunen
oft löst die pensionierte lehrerin
achter platten fahren
90 von katrin bitte bedienen sie sich
hier bringe ich ihnen noch fotos und
dokumente die ich gesammelt habe ich tue
ja schon 30 jahre
ich hätte nie gedacht dass ich mich so
lange mit den schweizer kommunarden
beschäftigen würde
schauen sie sein gesicht an so energisch
entschlossen als aber in gedanken
kämpfen würde also der globale aufgaben
lösen würde
die die ganze menschheit betreffen ich
würde nicht sagen dass die leute hier
ihn als helden sehen ein held ist nicht
einer wie wir alle er aber war wie alle
bloß hatte er ein außergewöhnliches
schicksal sein ganzes leben opferte er
der idee für die er immer kämpfte und
der er seine gesundheit und am ende auch
sein leben opferte
die letzte jahr was im lager für mit
moskau nachts im landwirtschafts
experiment hätte fritz platten hier
gewohnt und schaffet immer noch zieht
rom vom sozialismus und der
weltrevolution fragen
obwohl sitzt der oktoberrevolution
herzlich clark in der junge sowjetunion
radikal verändert der lenin und lassen
sie es egal und sie frontschürze 1924
vom stalin für sie macht festigen könnte
diktator trainingsgruppe erzählt des
terrorregimes mit unzähligen
arbeitslager für den aufbau vom land
millionen von menschen sterben
ausländer sind grundsätzlich verdächtig
politisch setzt der international ist
platten in der disco york erschossen und
eigentlich
er unterrichtet hat am ort wo aus
landerneau tode sie am fremdsprache
instituts moskau noch unter druck die
schweiz aber da denken die 20 jahre
jüngere schweizer kommunistin peter
zimmermann
[Musik]
sie ist charisma wirkt immer noch zehn
studentinnen klären
dort ist sie eine ehemalige studentin
die elena gina spätere historiker und
professorin
hier ist sie im film von den salzburgern
ins ziel wo mittlerweile gestorben ist
der fritzbox land bewundert uns dafür
kämpft dass man nicht vergisst
als ich vom sonic seliger und
lebenslustiges
[Musik]
in der lehre hat sie nie vergessen
das ist wirklich schematismus unter dem
ziel ist es menschen mit mit großem
glück
es ist an die freeskier der stalin
herrscht praktisch alle 1906 moskau die
erste show prozess
die autobahn von der bolschewiki wird
erschossen grund oder karama platten
empfang vom mächtigen kern gehen die
aktivität der historiker vom ehemaligen
so jetzt schauen wir nach der komischen
partei der schweiz vor audi charakter
für die taten sein muss ja sie können
das ist ein partei wie schon ja also
dann schauen wir mal einfach hier also
in jedem fall der sind die schweizer
akten und steht im bereich theater die
charakter und ja also sie finden es
schön dass es nur 100 ich glaube das
anliegen nicht falsch es stimmt dass es
platten fritz schweiz und die katarakten
nummer war alles ein bisschen geheim
waren mehr als ein bisschen werden
absolut wir haben und das ist ein lauf
in kopie es gibt viele die
handschriftlich sind und dann richtig
unterschrieben dann verschiedene pässe
und bürgschaften wie ich hier die diese
bürgschaft von der deutschen partei und
das konnte dann gegen ihn verwendet
werden was eher daran lässt was in der
katarakt aber konnte gegen entsprechende
person verwendet werden am
gefährlichsten waren eigentlich die
eingaben von anderen kollegen die
beschwerden die alles möglich ist mit zu
komponieren eingaben
denunziation ist axonic angst macht sich
breit
hunderte gewartet so ohne
gerichtsverfahren willkürlich verhaftet
und die zwangsarbeitslager gulag
deportiert
[Musik]
wie ein spinnennetz über ziert das
lagersystem das ganze land noch immer
glaubt aber schon berichte in der terror
in 237 wird seine frau bertha mit der
vater weniger schlag verhaftet und
erschossen und kurz darauf aber trifft
oder platten sauber dass allein in
russland brachte schutz nehmen
er wird zu vier jahre lagerhaft
verurteilt
[Musik]
und straflagern norden
und das immer wieder am anfang von der
geschichte mit einem dorf wo man die
jungen kadetten von platten verzerrt der
dorflehrer ford mit das lager ist mit 53
ist musik häftling gestorben
sogar jetzt kommt nicht platten an der
irrtum von der partei glaubt erstellt
das stalin drucksystem nitrat als in die
letzte freundin schreibt er ich bin das
produkt der allgemeinen situation und
darf nicht den kopf hängen lassen
wir gehen dadurch natürlich vorsichtig
passen sie auf das war mal ein werk und
das sind die überreste
sie legten bretter drauf damit man nicht
im sumpf versank vorsicht passen sie auf
wir gehen jetzt durch das ehemalige
lager gebiet nicht da wo die gefangenen
hier ist ein kleines verwaltungsgebäude
erhalten dahinter sei eigentliche lager
war dort die gefangenen lebten dort
hinten beraten
und davon ist nichts erhalten bretter
wurden weggebracht oder sie verfaulten
oder sind einfach verschwunden
hier interessant die holzschindeln sind
erhalten sie wurden von den gefangenen
hergestellt auch von fritz platten
als die freundin schritt betritt platten
ganz revolutionär
ich habe den krieg in der schweiz an der
seite lenins miterlebt und bedaure tief
jetzt hier holzschindeln machen zu
müssen jetzt wirklich zäh wie eine katze
sein und wenn möglich noch einmal mit
den europäischen arbeitern zur
verwirklichung und linien verlosungen
beitragen unser nördliches klima ist
hart eisige kälte im winter im sommer
stechmücken hier zu überleben bei mieser
unterkunft und schlechtem essen unter
ständiger bewachung
das war fast unmöglich die freundin
wenn du noch etwas schicken willst und
kannst so läge dem paket 2 ein
balanceakt bei damit ich mir für den
winter einen strohsack nähen kann und
weicher und wärmer liegen kann
denn die bloßen bretter drücken die
knochen
[Musik]
dass es für das fritz blattgemüse anders
ich trage ich sie meister vladimir
[Musik]
jurowski geworden
der fritz button am 22 april 1940 männer
erschossen
warum genau und wo ist nicht bekannt
die frage ob der schritt platten je
realisiert dass er seine eigenen
parteigenossen verrat und tod geschickt
haben wir gemerkt hat dass sie traum
dort pervertiert ist und nicht wie
menschenverachtend der festplatten ist
ihr sowjetunion aus die geschichtsbücher
strichen wurden erst nach dem tod von
stalin heizmann er rehabilitiert und die
beisitzer man wollte ich wieder ein
erinnern
der weggefährte von lenin woods
kommunistische system nie öffentlich
angriffe hat und vermutlich bis an die
frage lautet ist jeder herz der schweiz
seit der name fritz bart und homer bis
es geht kräftig mal eine straße nach ihm
benannt ist und chris einzig spur über
der arbeiter für normal so populär ist
sie
es ist aus hat man ihr gar
gradwohl kommunistische sie hat mir
vermutlich war der kalte krieg vertraut
und doch ist eine radikale idee bis
bedeckt was früher selbstverständliche
schweizer stimmrecht proporzwahl ahv und
dankbar
sie sieht vorkampfes im heutigen
sozialstaats
[Musik]